it's time now for one more thing geraldo
you talk about refugee crises it was one
in my family covering the war in
afghanistan 11 assignments over there i
forged a relationship with uh with a
fellow named akbar shinwari the guy on
the right there uh he was my guide he
saved my life numerous times there was
his with brother craig they're both my
brothers uh so we uh we got him out of
uh
you know uh
afghanistan uh it was a desperate uh
struggle thanks to uh fox news we got
him out he went first to the united arab
republics there he is when he got out
and now he's uh he's in america he and
the family are in america they're in
virginia they'll be coming to ohio
they'll be coming in
into my world i i promise you that akbar
is going to be gainfully employed i'm
going to sponsor the family uh we we
love them
we have there's a plenty afghan
community in uh in cleveland ohio so
they're going to have plenty of people
from where they hail your house
i have a big house i'm going to put in
one of those rooms i had for jesse that
i've never been in but
uh i'm delighted to welcome the shinwari
family they're watching right now
love you brother and uh you know welcome
to the usa delightful hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else